totally mental is a new show in downtown
and illusionist vinnie grosso is here to
tell us all about it welcome back to the
stage vinny
hi thank you of course now i assume
you've had plenty of virtual practice
during these times to keep you ready yes
yes
no it's magic with a twist right what
can people actually expect
well so it's i'm a magician comedy
magician and i'm taking on the world of
mentalism and
mentalists are usually very serious and
i find that kind of funny
so i'm gonna put a little twist on it
and make it comedy
a comedy magician that is definitely
unique i'm excited to see what you have
in store here so
what exactly should people expect during
the show what what are
do you combine mental tricks with magic
tricks how does that work
yeah well i basically say a magician and
a mentalist
are are similar with one difference
we both lie to you but a magician you
know is lying and a mentalist wants you
to think that it's true
so smart i i kind of take the the
the more i know we're lying uh aspect of
it
got you got you okay and there is also
audience participation but
safely right we'll explain that yeah and
and that
has to do with all my practice from
online shows so
i was able to kind of reinvent the show
so the audience participation happens
with
everyone sitting in their seats and
socially distant and
and it's still some of the magic is with
technology and cameras like you know
we're doing right now
and other stuff just happens right where
they are
in their head that's so in their head
right now how is there is there a
restriction on how many people can come
to the show
yes yes of course we're we're limited
with
the layout of our theater where we can
only do about 60 people right now
um with the restrictions yeah that's not
bad so how can people come on down and
catch you
well they can go to totallymental.info
slash tix
and uh they can get tickets and it's
downtown las vegas at notoriety and
they're
lots of other shows going up at this
venue as well it's just a fun place to
be
oh that's cool okay so it's friday
saturdays and sundays right
yes that's that's when i'll be there
okay vinnie thank you so much i'm
excited
thank you all right again tickets are 35
and you can get them online at
notorietylive.com kendall i'll send it
over to you thanks again vinnie